fully vaccinated people can visit with
other fully vaccinated people indoors
without wearing a mask or physical
distancing
visit with unvaccinated people from a
single household
who are at low risk of severe coping 19
disease
indoors without wearing masks or
physical distancing
and refrain from quarantine and testing
following a known covet 19 exposure if
the vaccinated person remains
asymptomatic
for now we will continue to examine this
in the upcoming weeks
as and update our guidance accordingly
fully vaccinated people should continue
to
take precautions like public in public
like wearing masks
and physical distancing wear well-fitted
masks and physically distance and adhere
to other prevention measures when
visiting
with unvaccinated people who are in
increased risk of severe coping
or who have an unvaccinated family
member household member who is an
increased risk of covid
wear masks physically distance and
practice other prevention measures when
visiting with
unvaccinated people from multiple
households
avoid medium and large-sized crowds get
tested of experiencing
19 symptoms follow guidance issued by
individual employers
and follow cdc and health department
travel recommendations